Okay, we are back
live.
Hi. Lots of good news today, man.
Today's just been a good day for
Puffer. Had a productive meeting
earlier. Got some stuff
merged. Spencer found a bug in the place
that I expected that there would be a
bug. So, I get to be smug about
that. And uh view drive is going to be
working.
Now, all I really got to do is a little
bit of work on the experience buffer and
we should
be pretty pretty solid. We should be
pretty solid with this latest version.
So, all I really wanted to do right
I think we figured
out good
enough realistically quite good
solutions for everything except
uh collecting experience on environments
with masking which is kind of the same
as like collecting experience on multi-
aent environments where the agents can
die. And uh we don't have any
environments right now where that is
mandatory but we do have some where that
option and we would like to be able to
train in that
setting. So,
uh yeah, I think I want to
like figure out what we do about that,
So before I could guarantee the batch
sizes would all be the same
size and now I
can't. This seems pretty
bad. There's not really a great way
around masking
either around uh this thing.
I mean the the fundamental concept here
I'm going to be like thinking about this
like exploring a bunch of technical
things but the fundamental concept is
you just get data that looks like this
right so it doesn't all match
up and that doesn't fit cleanly into an
experience
buffer I'm trying to think realistically
how often this happens anyways
It really only happens in
like elimination style games,
right? Like I have this issue in neural
MMO because it was a battle
royale. But like MMOs aren't really
battle royale, so I just made it not a
battle
royale. If you have really long
episodes, it shouldn't matter that much.
How's it currently handled by Puffer?
Just completely skip observations. Well,
in the current 2.0
branch, you know, what is this? First
time watching. This is reinforcement
learning
dev. I am uh I'm a researcher. I run
upper.ai.
These are all ultra high performance
games that we've implemented that you
can watch AIs that have been trained to
play these directly in your browser.
They're playing it directly in your
browser. You can like you can hold what
is it shift I believe and you can take
over and play the games. Some of them
are simple, some of them are complex.
But yeah, this is kind of just uh the
vibe around here is just watch research
get done in real time. And then uh
hopefully the streams convince some of
the people watching to also contribute
because it's all open source and many of
our best contributors just were people
who kind of saw the content and saw the
stuff and started building
things. What I'm doing right now is uh
I'm attempting to solve a technical
problem in the design of how we process
data that that comes in for training. So
pepper um what we were doing in
2 is we were collecting all the data to
a flat buffer. So we just record it as
it comes in out of order. We record the
indices of that
data and then right before we need to
train on it we sort all the data by the
indices. So we get the like segments for
each agent next to each other and then
we just reshaped it. So you know data
could cross boundaries. It could be that
you know you get the f the end of one
segment and then the start of the next
segment in the same batch. Um but like
it works cleanly and you just don't add
data to this buffer that's
masked. We can't really do that now
because what we're doing we're
collecting stuff by segment so that we
don't cross boundaries here.
And uh as a result of
that, I can't really see a clean way of
handling
tricky. Like the issue is that we're
filling up this
buffer. I guess the right question to
ask is what do we do when an agent dies?
Like fundamentally, what options do we
have when an agent dies? Right? So we're
getting data like this, data like this.
It's all nice data is here. And then
this one just
dies. Tell you I'm sold for working it
now. Awesome.
It's kind of um the cool thing about
reinforcement learning, at least the way
we're doing it, is you can kind of just
jam low-level game development
um and help revolutionize a branch of
science at the same
time. And like you can do it without
that much compute as well. Let me give
you one really cool example. So this is
neural MMO 3. This is a follow-up to my
PhD thesis. And uh this is like this big
open world MMO environment. There's like
a market you can like you can sell and
buy stuff on a global market. Like
there's all sorts of complexity to this
thing. This thing runs at 1.5 million
steps per second per core. Um so this
thing runs like literally a million
times real time. And we can train on one
GPU in like three days. We can train on
2,000 years worth of
gameplay which is pretty cool.
and then you can run the trained model
on like one CPU more
easily. So yeah, this is this is what
I'm trying to do, right? I'm trying to
revolutionize this area of of AI. I'm
really trying to make stuff clean, fast,
and simple.
Um, I spent my whole PhD working on
largecale multi- aent learning in the
space and now I'm sort of turning to try
to like make it practical, make all the
infrastructure fast and simple, uh, and
make it way more broadly applicable to a
ton of different
things. Sometimes that involves doing a
bunch of like fun programming on stream.
Sometimes it involves stuff like this
where I have to think about data
structures for a couple
hours. Okay. Fundamentally, the issue
with this data structure here,
right, the issue is that I plan for
these to get
longer. Pepper here from Twitch just
switched to YouTube. Hey, Pepper.
Yeah, you're
um I mean the guy has so many
different names. Where where did he go?
You're Weston's friend, right?
Yeah, this isn't going to be a problem.
Like we can't keep it as is, right? We
can't have our data buffers look like
this where this all gets wasted because
what always always ends up happening in
like elimination style games is that
there just two players at the end for a
really long time. I
mean, this has got to be applicable
outside of just like games as well.
There have got to be environments that
I'm going to run into where like this is
going to be an
issue. I'm just trying to think if
there's like a decent fix. I will take
if it just is a little bit of padding
and I like lose a little bit of data.
I'm fine with that. It just can't be
this. But it's tricky because like you
have to reuse this index then somehow,
right? You have to like put data from
another agent here or something.
Okay, here this is kind of
complicated but like in theory
right if I just had all the free
indices so this is like we have like one
index here these are like active
And this is going to start off like zero
one say 10 24
8192. Impulse war. Impulse war is
trained fine on box two. also alternated
between 145 and 230 SPS. PR could be
ready. Awesome. Let me finish these
thoughts and then I'll merge that. Also,
the profiling I don't think is accurate
on the latest dev. I have to fix that
today as well. Let me see if I can
figure this out first because I think I
might have I don't even necessarily want
to implement this now. I just want to
know that I have the way of doing this
before I lock in the new experience
buffer
design. Okay. Like if an agent dies,
right? Can't I just technically, let's
say agent two
dies, can I not just append
it? Or even better, can I not just like
prepend
it? Would that work?
so. that like this is technically a
possibility because then when you need
more free indices you just grab them
from
here posted twice captain.
Um, okay. But the other question here is
actually like how likely is this
scenario that we end up with
um are we realistically going to want to
collect more than like 128?
Because typically in puffer we run a lot
of parallel environments for compute
efficiency. So like 1024 environments
times
128 that's already million, right?
That's already a
million. No, I'm
dumb. That's 120k. I'm
stupid. Okay, but we run more than 1024
environments. Usually we run like 4096.
So that's
like there's not going to be a point in
backcropping
more than 120. There's just no way with
current architectures it matters.
The only benefit is longer rollouts let
you compute advantage over longer
horizons. How confident am I that we're
going to need long horizon advantage
computation longer term?
on one hand like
fundamentally I'm not confident that you
have to compute long trajectories to
learn
stuff but that's going to be dependent
on a bunch of future research and so far
it has seemed really important for what
we've been
doing so we'll call that a toss
up I I think ultimately the conclusion
here is
that we don't deal with masking right
now. We don't have any active projects
that require masking, but we have a way
to steer if we do end up requiring
masking. Uh and also
technically, could I implement this in
CUDA? I'm pretty confident I could
implement this operation very
efficiently in CUDA if I had to.
Yeah, because you don't actually need to
append stuff. You could have a fixed
size list and you could just like
overwrite existing
values. Okay, I'm confident that I could
do this efficiently if I had to down the
line. Have you tried to have you thought
about trying to perform transfer
learning from one of the games, say
search and rescue with a multimodal
approach if possible that runs 3D? So,
here's the issue with that type of
thing. I just talked with a company
that's doing cool work in that space
now.
Um, the issue with like trying to do
transfer, it doesn't work like train on
one environment and then transfer to
something totally different. The only
way that works and the only way that
that's been demonstrated to work in
other areas of AI is train on a ton of
tasks and then transfer to something
kind of similar or kind of in that
space. Um, that is just a much larger
scale of research. like fundamentally
yes we could technically do it but now
we're talking about needing hundreds of
games and probably needing at least
hundreds of GPUs like for these runs
whereas for what we're doing we can
still get our fundamental research done
on all these methods uh we can train on
like billions or tens or hundreds of
billions of steps and we can do it on
like one GPU per run
so we're doing pretty darn efficient
research for compute now that type of
like generalization stuff is out there
like yeah we're interested in it but um
not at present
scale. Is this problem related to just
the sampling of the experience buffer?
Are you talking about the buffer for
puffer m just the sampling of the
experience buffer?
Um I technically have a very large
improvement to make on our vectorization
uh by integrating uh by having the
option to use torch tensors in the
vectorzation itself. But it's going to
be way easier for me to implement that
thing and it's going to be way simpler
if I just wait until Python has good
threading. And probably if by 3.14 they
still don't have good threading, I'm
just going to do it in C is most likely
what's going to
happen. But if Python actually gets
threading to work correctly, then we
will be able to do that very very
nicely. We'll be able to have like very
very nice improved vectorzation
uh with that. At
least I think we should be able
to. You need to be able to have uh you
need to be a basically be able to share
slices of torch tensors with different
workers and because those are on
different processes right now it breaks
but if they were to be in
um on different threads it should work.
Welcome YouTube folks.
Okay, so I think that the conclusion of
all of this is that uh this is probably
still a good buffer design.
Realistically, this covers like 95% of
the cases that we want to learn on. It
does it way better than the previous
version of the code. There's a 5% of
cases that the previous code covered
that this just doesn't cover at all. But
if we really had to, we have an
efficient way of handling that.
I think that's the conclusion from this
section which is good. That's like
that's a good
outcome. Anything from Spencer
here? Expert
trajectories on the
first
256 have 7% collision and 2% off road.
So, I may need to prune the data
set. Interesting. Probably the data
set's just
noisy. Okay. Um, so I think that what
we're going to do now, it's 2:30. I
think I'm going to work on the
experience buffer code a little bit. Uh
I'm not going to handle masking but I'm
going to see if I can get all the other
edge cases out so that this thing
generally behaves sely. Actually there
is one other problem that we need to
solve I believe first uh which is quite
a bit
simpler. There's been this weird
indexing bug that I just need to think
through right now. The way that we store
data
like our most common setup is something
like
this. So you got like one 10 24 rows 10
24 rows.
We can
have offset infos for each dimension
that help create an original
tensor. But then you're training
on wait offset and
post. So then you're training on m like
you're training on padding right?
You ideally don't want to train on
padding because it's a waste of compute
resources. Like I had this issue in my
PhD a whole bunch where you would get
like 5% data density. So you're throwing
away 95% of your compute if you train on
the padding even if you mask
it. So the goal is to create dense data,
not the
pad. And in 95% of cases it works as is.
And in 5% of cases, the thing that I
discussed before should allow you to
create dense data where you're basically
like when you run out on one access or
whatever, when you get like to the end
of a agent lifespan, you're going to use
the next piece of that segment for
another
agent. And the indexing I had there
should
work.
Okay.
So, the way that this needs to work
is you
put data into each of these
buffers. And what I was doing right now
is I was having a free index. So I was
saying how many rows do you have left
that are
free? And what was happening is if you
had exactly like the exact number of
agents as you had data rows, then you
have no more indices free. So even
though you have spare room in this
buffer, it wasn't picking it up. So I
think what I have to do is something
based on episode
lengths. If I make a hard assumption
that we're always going to fill in the
correct order, I think I can do this.
And I can just add a check to make sure
I don't screw this up.
So I think what I do is I do like numbum
like
full
rows and then when you get to the
end I increment
this. That way I'm not looking for extra
rows. I'm looking for how many are
full. And I didn't want to do this
before because the masking thing, but I
think we're actually fine with the way
that this
is. Yeah, this should be 100% fine.
Okay, that wasn't that
hard. I guess I was just uh tired before
or whatever. Let's uh let's implement
this very very carefully because this is
the type of thing where you can
introduce large bugs. Check one other
thing in Discord.
here. We're going to put a we'll put a
warning on
that. This has to be
like full rows.
How about full
rows is less than on policy
rows. And it doesn't even need to be in
data, does
it? We'll do this for now.
So what I was doing right
now is I was incrementing this like free
index. You do need a free index, don't
you?
rows. But this is the same freaking
code, isn't
it? No, this is not the same code
because they start at different
values. These Yeah, these different
values.
Okay, that was the thing that I couldn't
figure out before. You need to count
both the free what index you're going to
fill next and you need to count how many
rows you have full. Those are different
pieces of information.
We'll like make sure a couple
environments run and then we will do
captain's PR and then uh with the next
couple hours afterwards, assuming that
that goes well, we will continue to
clean up this code a
bit. 50 second breakout solve. That is
actually faster than before as well. I
think we were throwing away some data or
something
before. We must have been like throwing
away some
data. Let's also just add a decent
warning while we're here.
That's decent. Endur MMO frames 400k
with the big model. Pretty
decent. We're
happy. Make sure I didn't screw it up
with that uh that
warning. That's good. Cool.
He said that this was ready,
right?
18,000 lines.
Holy. You must have committed something
you shouldn't have committed,
right? 18,000 lines,
ma'am. Yeah. So, let me just merge that
real quick. Hang
on. Fine
format. I don't mind dirty merging this,
but holy hell,
man. I know the end of it is like 8K.
Where's the other 10K coming from?
to be determined whether or not we
accept
CMake. And we'll either accept that
though or uh find something
better and we'll get
merged. I'm like waiting for the joke
file that's like 10,000 lines of
haha. Okay, these we've reviewed
already.
We did like a full review of this
environment. Took like two or three days
on
it. Oh, you
included All right. You included source
files for um
for some dependencies. It seems probably
there's like another one of
these. Yeah, DL Malik. There you go. So,
it's it's big because
of not a fan of the bender depths like
this. Makes it annoying for us to like
keep track of our code base size and
stuff.
Does anybody know how GitHub tracks like
line counts and stats? Can I put stuff
in like external or something and have
it not count
it if we're going to do that?
well. We actually will get to run this
end in a few minutes. Um, if I can get
this integrated and set up. It's a
really cool environment. It's like
really, really a cool environment. All
credit to Captain for uh the code on
this. I helped with I helped with some
of the front end for
it. Okay, so we're going to approve
this. This
beast
now. Not fan of
of
dependency files
this workflow requires approval from a
maintainer.
question. Yeah. No, it doesn't require
it's just getting
merged.
Okay, let's see if we can get this to
run. I want to run the uh the renderer
for this. It's a really cool end. Very
happy to have this popper in any
state. Yeah, there it is. 18,000 lines.
So, if we ignore like the was it 10,000
lines of
dependencies? Um, what is it?
10,000? Not quite. It's like 8,000
lines. So, like a 10k line PR. Um, that
is probably a half or a third of the
size of the Puffer Code base. Probably
like a third the size of all of Puffer.
So, this is a very big end.
Uh, did Captain tell me how to compile
it? CM
make. Is there a separate setup or
something? Oh, there's a tunnel.
work. So yeah, the thing that's tricky
on the infrastructure side of this is
like this has a couple extra
dependencies that are annoying to build
and link. So Captain just use CMake for
it. Um I really do not like CMake.
I really hope that we can find a way to
just like have a really simple build
script that just does this and cut out
all the extra dependency and stuff, but
we will see. I figured we will merge it
for now so that we can run experiments
on it. I kind of want to have all the
new M's uh checked into
Puffer and that also lets me iterate on
the models a little bit to help out the
uh to help them out on this.
imple
runs it does not render.
Okay. Uh I guess you have to put render
equals through in the
Holy.
Um, that doesn't seem to be the intended
Captain, I imagine that this is because
it has
And we can hack it for
now. There we are.
So this is just the uh
built-in like scripted opponent versus a
random agent random neural
net rendering at I don't
know this is not real time. This is
faster than real
time. But yeah this looks
sweet. We got to fix resolution. We got
to fix like render arcs and stuff. But
this is
sweet. This is going to be so cool to
have in puffer.
Okay, I'm going to rename it to puffer
impulse force.
Then we're going to see what
uh
Holy Takes a second to
compile.
Shenanigans. I kind of want to disable
this annoying compile stuff to be
honest. I don't think it makes anything
much
annoying. It's
dead. Is
now? Okay.
Refresh. Internet blip, I guess. Or
reream server blip.
So, I did find
something. Hi. Are you building a game
using reinforcement learning? We're
building a large number of games and
using reinforcement learning on
them. They're all on puffer.ai, at least
the one so far. We have more in
development.
Everything from like breakout up to more
complicated and interesting things like
this mini
here. You can join the Discord to get
involved with the development of it if
you're
interested. Okay, I think the stream is
back. We had a little bit of a like
server bug. I dropped a ton of frames,
but should be good now.
Um, yeah, Captain. I It dropped like a
ton of frames. It was just the reream
servers being
bugged and I might have to get a
different provider for that. Their
servers grew up once in a
while. So, I found
this replacement equals
false. Discord link. Absolutely. It's
very easy to remember.
Most of our contributors came in with
zero RL experience as well and are now
contributing very very productively. So
I don't know your background, but if you
can code, you're probably
good. Replacement
false. This is sketchy to
me. It should be replacement true,
right?
way? Yeah, look the default in torch
says
true. So if I just do
um multinnomial
so. Oh, you know what? Hang on. Let me
get one more data point on this and then
I have an idea.
Okay, so this isn't faster on its own,
but what about if I do
both? Cuz it could be that the
concatenated
one still has the replacement
[Music]
overhead. Did you see the small changes
I made to
demo.py? Uh, I did not.
I'm trying to fix the multinnomial
sampling thing at the moment for
you. I'm actually very surprised that
doesn't fix it.
Okay. Well, what else does this do? So,
this calls
multinnomial and then it calls reshape
and that's
it. I mean that's the whole operation
We should probably just get the torch
profiler out or something,
right? Torch profiler is such a
pain. But I think that's probably what
we have to do.
was able to figure out.
Yeah, it's just kind of annoying.
It's hard to read. Yeah, I know. That's
why I don't like
it. Can we do something like this real
quick?
No. If I just do
total. Let's see if this does anything.
I'm
So sample logits total
is 200 micro
seconds
multinnomial. This seems pretty evenly
distributed, doesn't it?
30% in
sum
gather
copy. That seems pretty evenly
distributed to me.
But you can see here it's um it's CPU
time, isn't
it? Oh, here it is. It is the
multinnomial multinnomial
taking a whole bunch of time.
It's all CPU
Okay. So, do we need to look at the
multinnomial code then?
Oh, and then there's a scatter inside of
it. Okay. What is underscore
Didn't I just read the categorical
source code and see if it had
multinnomial in
it? Or am I going
crazy?
Wait,
what? Categorical calls
multinnomial and multinnomial makes a
categorical. Yeah, we're not happy with
that.
Is there a way to find where the source
is for
It seems like it's
um
multinnomial. It seems like it calls
this.
So then I don't understand how these
things fit
categorical and then this
does the sample on
So wait, this
is of a this is a
check that doesn't do
anything. How does this make any sense?
So multinnomial
right we get to
here then this makes a
categorical and then this
multinnomial which takes prob sample
shape
right? Is it
this? This is
But I mean this is defined unless this
import gets overridden
multinnomial. It's got to be this,
right?
There's an underscore
here. Do these import
star. Okay, this init file is not going
to be particularly useful. So, I can't
tell what the hell it's calling.
to do this
multinnomial. Was there a time
multinnomial in this
this? Where did I uh I put this? Here it
is.
right does this mean that the hang on if
I see the overhead in a 10 multinnomial
This is 1.7
ms. And then this says that I
have like 300 ms micro uh 300 micro of
that in these ops. So then where's the
rest of it?
The actual
um multial isn't that slow. It's
probably the rapper blue,
right? Do we even need this? Is there a
simpler way of doing this?
Num
samples indices are sampled from the
multinnomial.
Okay, so you make a categorical and it
calls
multinnomial and then it can it can
potentially do more than one sample I
guess.
And
like it's probably this
thing cuz this is a 10 multinnomial
input utils graph
context and then it's by
name. I'm very confused if this is not
just a prop
sample. Is this doing anything other
than just
like sampling based on prob and giving
you log prop returned?
props. You can give this thing logit to
start
with. I think you can do even better
than
that. We're
going to ask dumb questions and get some
dumb
answers. Multial sample doing anything
other than just giving
is. Okay, so like this goes through a
whole bunch of garbage.
Semicorn
basic GPU.
I'm just looking if there's like a lower
level function for this.
same. I remember that from a totally
different context from like years ago.
Yeah, this is different. This is so that
you can compute
gradients. So I do remember this
correctly.
So, it is actually interesting to think
about that. I haven't thought about that
in a while. So,
thanks. It's small. What do you mean?
No, it's the the function is
screwy. Their function has like 10
layers of you don't
like I I was interning under this guy as
a high school student about in this time
period. That's funny as hell. This is
from 2018, man.
old,
right? Where did I just put your
Funny to see your time come 15
minutes free. What you want me to do?
Yeah, this isn't what we want either. I
have installed instructions PR for
building. You weren't using the latest
version. What do you mean I wasn't using
the latest
version?
What? The PR that I merged wasn't the
latest version?
pip install- e dot doesn't do it from
the impulse wars
Well, I I pip installed from your
directory with your pipe like your
Isn't it just like argument of a or
something? I have DSA algorithm. I don't
know
nothing. Should probably
study. That's what I would suggest.
I literally had to look uh look that up
like last week or whatever because I
it's just domain. It's um data
structures and algorith just a standard
fang
annoying like solve tricky impractical
questions
live. All right, with the advertising
like shouldn't it just be internally
doing like argument
of rand less than some
Yeah, I did fix
that. I might have rebroken it. We'll
see.
But fully compiles the uh the eval the
eval
pass. And then the backward is mostly
fast with
2DN. That's been a thing for a while,
but
So, this actually does noise on
GPU. So, hang on. We should be able to
do something with this then if we're a
little clever, right?
possible. So the idea here is we just
bypass the all the multinomial
shenanigans. Argument CUDA is not
implemented for
What is the size and
shape
categorical? Yeah, it's just they just
give you some probabilities, man. And
it's like for some reason something is
slow.
Okay, we still
have 40% time in forward
pass. Not
ideal. Goal for
today, mostly cleaning up the uh
experience buffer, improving performance
on that. And uh Captain just PR this
like 10,000 line environment that's
currently bottlenecked by action
sampling. Plus I've had a couple other
requests for that. So I'm spending a
little bit of time seeing if I can
improve that right now. And then if I
have time after that I will probably go
back to cleaning up the experience
buffer, getting some new experiments
running and things like that. You need
to fix the panel
profiling. That is true.
I don't know. We can answer whatever you
want. It's a free country.
So, okay. So, now I see soft
max. Soft max in here
is taking up the
time. Uh, where the heck should Softmax
be getting called?
here? What is this? I just like torch
profile
Okay. Okay. If I do this, is this
included?
Okay, so there's
still soft
So when you call multinnomial does it do
this
internally? Okay, this does do a soft
max.
What you have to do,
right? You have to do a soft max for
this. So that's now what's taking up the
time.
and A10 soft max is mostly on the uh it
is on the CPU
here we are deep in PyTorch code not
that deep to be
fairly barely getting to the C++
I want to see if this
calls uh if this calls logistics to
probs or
something. So when you do
this because here you can give it
logits,
right? Yeah, you're allowed to give this
thing logits and then it just saves
this
It norms
it or gives it logic. This is self
param and then underscore innit or
whatever. So underscore innit on
distribution. Does this have
anything. I don't see any normalization
happening
there. So you do this thing, right?
Logit minus
this that gives logits and
then oh yeah props is logit to probs.
Cool. So logits to probs.
There you
go. It just does soft
max. So logistic problems on. So it
normalizes and then does
Wait, isn't this the
same some act
logs? We still need the props, right?
Because we need log props.
bet. Well, but the thing is it's not
even like really okay. This whole thing
is like massively written out to be more
confusing than this is. Look, this is
literally all that's happening.
Okay, this is all the math that that you
need. You don't need to know anything
about stats or distributions or
anything. P 0, P1,
P2,
P3. These are numbers that sum to one.
Okay. Then let's say this is like 0.1,
this is like 2, this is like three, and
this was like 04. All right, these sum
to one. So what this is going to do is
it generates a random number. Let's say
it's
0.45 and then it
goes is this number bigger than this?
No. Okay, let's add this. Let's add this
to the sum. Is the sum of these two
bigger? No, it's not. Okay, let's keep
going.
Is this one bigger if I add this one?
Yes, it is. So, this is the best one.
So, 012 and it's going to return index
two. That's the entire
operation. There's just there's
additional normalization and stuff, but
that's the entire
operation. So, this is not really
complicated. Yeah, there is some like
the thing is you don't get
probabilities, you get logits which is
like you have to then transform those
into probs and usually you throw that
through a softmax for numerical
stability. But uh like conceptually you
don't need to know anything about
advanced prob or stats or anything like
it's really really basic. It's just
there are 10 layers of code for
something that is very
simple. So that's all I have to figure
out how to get around.
like this here is this is for numerical
stability and then the soft max is
technically also for numerical
stability. So
like let me see what quantities we need.
Do we ever need
probs? So we need log
prop and entropy.
broadcast. Okay. So this one doesn't
make a ton of sense to me.
Let me just like paste this and ask some
questions here. I'm
confused. I'm very confused on
this. Hey YouTube folks, welcome. We're
currently doing numerical optimizations
on our uh RL inference path,
specifically the action
fast. Actually, let's just copy all
this.
cumulative
distribution in the B
Isn't that just like incredibly
stupid? Wait, is that actually how
things Why the hell would you binary
search when you're computing the
cumulative
distribution? You should just be able to
like get the index in the process of
computing the
CDF or the cumitive distribution, not
CDF.
like you I showed you right you don't
need to binary search it you only need
to like binary search it if you have a
really long array and like you're doing
this the sum
first well because in this case you
literally get the answer in the process
of doing the cumulative
sum
right so Technically, yes, you can
improve over the one that I wrote. Uh,
but you'd have to write a
kernel. I just did cumulative sum, but
the thing is we still have uh it's still
now we still have the soft max and the
soft max is slow. So now my thing is
fast, but there's still the soft max
sample, the soft max. Um, so I'm trying
to see if we can combine some
operations.
anything. And then we replace this
where the multinnomial is.
So we just
[Music]
do I guess it's just going to be
like
dumbbell and then you still need normal
objects but just avoid soft max
Maybe I guess this makes sense because
like the action distribution doesn't
have to be differentiable, right?
Okay. So, now we can see what's wrong
with this film.
Allocate a giant ass
class CDFS lookup
table. Generate a bunch of random
numbers.
Make your own cuda. Your own included
that avoids all the stupid size
Uh it's really weird how like every
single thing I've tried is about the
same
speed. Like Now it's bottlenecked by a
random number gen. It seems it's also
all CPU bottleneck which is
weird. Ideally eager mode should also be
fast.
This random noise
[Music]
is you always need to regenerate the
noise, right?
good. I mean, we got it right. Where is
it? Right here.
Right. Rand likes 800.
It's one rand. It's a random number per
action option.
high? Does this not like generate the
noise on GPU?
Okay, this is
something. Yeah, I don't know what
that's doing.
Uh, how about if we c we can catch the
tensor if not the noise, right? So we
don't have to keep remaking it. Maybe
that helps.
then make sure you plot the R. I'm not
catching the RNG. I'm just catching the
storage tensor, Okay.
I'm kind of tempted to bet, but I don't
really think you
right? Is this like some dumb thing
where you have to get it from a certain
stream or something? So like it's not
parallelizable.
bunch of internal checks. Technically,
it could be that it is it is CPU time.
Do they have like are they doing checks
per element or something? That
guy. Welcome, Peanut.
Size check should not account for this.
They would have to be checking every
element or
something. Hang on. Let me just check
for ghosts real
quick. Is that faster or did I just get
lucky? No, I just got lucky.
Okay, see you, man. Good
luck. Make sure you have your work
saved. Boxes are getting shipped or
carried or whatever
potentially. What about tweaking some
consoles? What?
Well, I shouldn't rely on
um I shouldn't rely on this. I want to
do the end to end
speed. See if that has changed anything
because there's a ton of overhead in the
profiler. So, let's see if this has
changed anything.
No. Uh because compiling is a pain in
the ass
generally and like if you want a library
that only works properly in full compile
mode like use jacks.
or Tiny. Actually, if I wanted a library
that only works in compile mode, I'd use
Tiny. It's like dramatically better
software.
mean, I could technically cack the
noise.
Let me try that real quick. Cuz if that
doesn't work, then nothing's going to
work.
tricky. I don't want to spend all day on
it, but I will try something.
Now you get to like the key thing here
is we get to comment this out right
Yeah. Okay. So, now we profile it and
see what the heck it says.
I'm starting to suspect the profiler
anything. Nope. That's what it says. It
said add is taking time.
No, we're not making
environments continuous over this
We're going to solve the
problem.
I imagine this is like a combination of
profiling being dumb and a few other
things like just being hazy.
Did I uh I think I screwed up something
here. Hang
Okay, so that gives you
250. Um, this is still incredibly
freaking
slow, right?
Can't do that actually because it's
uh these ones need to actually be back
then. 128 a m*
16 48 plot buffered. Yeah, you can't do
that.
Is the end really going to bottleneck
that hard?
ends? It really shouldn't be hard
bottleneck on ends.
copies. Really shouldn't have to quad
buffer.
Eight.
Six. about
Okay. It's just the end being
slow. It's hard to get around.
You get way more
reasonable ratios.
Now, aside from the M, the M's just
being slow.
So it really was just small batch
training, huh?
What do I have this on
now? 6. Is this Yeah, it's 496. So, this
is the correct number of M to
have for training for sure.
does. When are you moving the boxes?
Probably tomorrow.
So it doesn't do
anything. Is that the uh the conclusion
here?
Oh, well this is doing everything
right. Hang on.
I mean, this action sampling stuff
really doesn't seem to make a damn
difference.
I can definitely optimize this a bit
without doing the dumbbell softmax
stuff, right?
Yeah, cuz this thing
does props.
Yeah, all these operations are just kind
of
sucky.
Um, let me think how we want to do this.
this. You only need the loops for
multi-iscipe.
So, what we're going to
do now, what we'll do is we'll
I think there's a good way to clean this
up. It's just going to take a little
work.
speed now. Okay, there's some ops we can
potentially save.
I think we're just redoing a ton of
operations in this, right?
Then log prop. What did I do for log
prop?
We are going to get a speed up out of
this
today. It's going to
have log prop should get you a
dimension. So, I think that this is just
wrong
then. Is this not supposed to be
summing
Yeah, I guess I didn't account for that
now, did
I? Okay, we'll debug it in CUDA, I
guess.
logits to problems on. This should be
normalized logic, shouldn't it?
getting
somewhere. At the very least, it will
clean up the code a
bit. At the best, it should be a bit
faster once we get to work.
You can't do log of normalized problems
or whatever.
Let's see what the
[Music]
original what did they do in the
original code here? There's a log
prop this one
entropy. Okay. So you take normalized
logits and logits to probs
of logits
times logits to probs.
thing. This doesn't do any expensive
ops, right?
Okay, it
runs. Probably not any faster,
So once I clean this up a little bit,
right?
Like this one's fast. This other one's
also fast.
prompts. We'll leave
the profiling in for right now, I guess.
Oh, well it's actually it is fast now
because of the
uh the different
params. So I guess this is the current
thing, right? This is the new
code. Uh so this is an upgrade. And then
if this runs, what we'll do is we'll try
the original and see if it's any faster
on the original.
have we've got this. So this will be
quad
buffered and then hopefully with quad
buffering it should be a little
better. Maybe not.
Right then. What was the original like
param or whatever in here?
I guess it was 60. No,
128. Is it 128 quad
buffer? 128 quad
buffer. So that's going to be like very
low batch size.
better. Shaved like 20% overhead off of
the afford pass.
runs pretty much the same now on any of
those
settings. It's not
bad. All right. Now we have to make sure
we didn't break everything
why haven't changed some stuff? I think
you left comments
somewhere. Would they be in the PR?
Maybe. Yeah, that's not cool to change
that.
Oh, you just added an extra arg. I see.
Okay. I'll have to fix stuff so it's
easier to add. We just All policies need
to take parts. That's the
thing. So, if we just
do, let's say we're not going to do this
crazy random noise thing.
Man, maybe we should try it. I spent the
time
whatever. Uh pre-allocated noise
stuff seems like it makes a very like it
makes a small difference. I don't know.
Is it worth leaving that in there?
versus it's kind of sketchy is the thing
like the alternative is to just do
this was like 228
Okay. Oh, hang on. I think it doesn't
make a
Good for
pass. I turn on sitting
ducks. M time. Why is m time less with
sitting
ducks? Is it because it's a one v one?
Like I What?
is so we do this and now it goes from
270.
Total time steps is 10 mil by
default. So, not
bad. Got to make sure it actually works
on the other
ends. So, we're keeping that guy's
chain, but we're fixing some other
solve. Pretty good. Let's make sure it
works with
three.
Solid. Okay.
Well, how's that for
um little perf improvement? We cleaned
up the code and we made it a bit
right? And then you can figure out the
demo thing. Well, or I can actually to
be fair. You can just change it locally
for now.
Go send this to the other person who
wanted this.
Neural MMO 3 was good on
box.
Interesting. Oh, we can always get it
sent in if we
need. It's fine.
So, I've got like another half hour
before
dinner, possibly longer. We'll see. I'm
going to take a couple quick minutes,
grab myself a drink, and then uh we will
do a little bit more clean up on the
experience buffer, a little bit more
optimization, and uh just generally a
little bit more work on getting this
into a good spot. Be right back.
Okay. Cool. Impulse
Wars running at a respectable
speed. I guess we have this perf profile
right here for us, don't we? For neural
MMO 11%
miss. That's pretty darn well optimized
other than the copy overhead, which is
actually. Let me check that. I'm pretty
sure the dtype is right on that. Should
be pretty small.
1700.
Um,
wait, how's it
1700? That seems big.
what? Oh, it is 10 channels. Okay. I
forgot I did that.
way. I have this fancy bit packing
stuff,
but 10% overhead to not have to do that
is
not I suppose.
So,
um, was there anything else that I had
to actually do on the experience buffer?
Is it
ready? I think the CPU fallback doesn't
work right now on
uh on the
right, let's fix cuda
build. Should be pretty easy.
steps? Okay, so this vrace check
signature I think just changed, right?
But this now
takes values rewards done
importance vss advantages nonsteps
horizon
Do we use
[Music]
that? There's no
right? Oh, this is actually passed
in. Okay.
cuda b trace check. Oh, and now we're
calling it with the wrong. Oh.
And you don't pass
in trace either, do you? This is just
fully
checked. So wait this was the signature
right? So you pass in values, rewards,
dums,
importance,
And then you don't have trace. You don't
need to return
this. And now the other ones are going
to error the exact same way. So that's
easy.
Importance. Yeah. So this doesn't give
you
trace.
Oh, I see. So literally it's just the
advantages. Yeah, we're going to have to
figure out how to reduce boiler plate in
this thing, but not today.
Okay, we're just going to get this to
run.
So
here B trace
what? Well, that would screw up
everything.
happen? Oh, yeah. That would definitely
break some stuff, huh?
BS and advantages. Yeah, there's a lot
of stuff in
here. Oh, but it's only in the CPP. It's
not in the CUDA, right?
So, this fall back was wrong. It's not
like I had it wrong in here. Yeah, this
is fine. Okay, I got worried for a
second. That would have been a really
bad bug. But if it's just in the fall
back, that's not really it for anything.
But debugging is
fine. Like, at least it's nowhere near
as bad as otherwise,
There's just a ton of boiler plate
involved with like
binding the C to CUDA and
C++ like your PI bind with torch. The
actual logic like the kernel is really
easy or at least simple maybe not
easy but
uh it's a pain.
Yeah, this is
box
Importance. It's a little silly to have
these giant signatures repeated
everywhere. Otherwise, there really
wouldn't be much code. Um, I don't know.
Maybe I'll find some way around that.
But yeah, so actually the training is
very very slow
now. Most likely because of this
current. Uh, actually the kernel should
be under miss, shouldn't
it? Oh yeah, there we go. 200k on CPU.
Totally acceptable.
Let's make sure I haven't broken
GPU and we'll push Yes.
Still trains quite
nicely. Trains quite nicely
indeed. 11% MISK is a little bit
annoying. 11% MISK is not that great. I
have also profiling fixes to make at
like 15 minutes probably.
I'd also like to set up some runs
though with the latest code
Um, hang on. Let me figure this out real
quick.
Okay.
So, I kind of want to try some network
[Music]
changes, but I I actually want to have a
baseline on the current version with the
layer norm.
with the layer norm. So, I think we're
just going to let this be as
is.
Um, yeah, that's what we're going to do.
And we're going to just SSH to the new
box. I'm think I'm just going to bring
both of these boxes next to me to the
new
facility cuz like
I'd like to have two personal
ones just right there where I can get to
them
easily. No changes to neural MMO. At
least there shouldn't be.
So
chunks
and make sure the config looks good.
Change this for now because of Experian
buffer
that. Batch and mini batch are the same.
And is that
moment. Set this new box up
for what I
need. Okay.
This will give me the Neptune token
prompt. Just
I'm going to run
this like so. And then I will check the
perf. If perf is low, I'm going to go
back to the older BPT horizon. I think
it should probably be good.
do Yeah, we'll do BPT Horizon
32. This will match the
original
curves. That should match our original
curves.
pretty
good.
570k. It's kind of crazy how fast like
and well optimized neural MMO is
compared to some of our others.
I think I can make it even faster to be
honest with you.
have we should have a
Neptune run
here with neural
MMO already getting us
score.
Mhm. Very nice. Probably 35 mil or
whatever.
So we can leave that
be other changes and
things profiling maybe.
Let's see if profiling seems
correct. We'll just do a basic
division. See if it makes
sense. So 1.6 six mil and then however
long it
80 over 50 is in fact 1.6 mil. Profiling
seems
accurate. Good.
So then if profiling is accurate, we can
use
it. Uh we should be able to use it to
mess with some perf
numbers. Breakout has obnoxiously high
copying
time. Really does, doesn't
it? Not much I'm going to be able to do
to get around that, though.
So, let's just let's just play with
stuff based
there? No, not
really. 32 is kind of maxed. What about
16 16k? Is that maxed?
you get a little bit of benefit out of
this. And then that's with batch PPT
Horizon 64. So let's do
524 8192 perfectly.
And then
327 here's a batch size of five full
sequences. That should be pretty good.
Um me run this
again. Any other pars that matter
particularly. Now the thing is I don't
know if this is going to optimize the
same. I wouldn't be surprised if this
fails. We'll do a very quick
um just
manual fiddle with learning rate. See if
it still solves type of a thing.
almost
almost if I just
delete these other
things. What happens?
should be roughly on
par. Oh, also these atom betas
This is kind of ridiculous if you look
at it, isn't
it? 2.6
mil. I'm going to be honest. I don't
really know where the extra perf came
from, but like I'll take it.
Okay, so that's 30 seconds, 855, which
is almost a solve. Not
quite. Let me try a linear schedule real
quick.
different. What about no one kneeling?
This I expect to break.
So, we pretty much have to figure out a
way to get um mini batch size higher on
the smaller models
because 2.7 million SPS is
ludicrous. Interesting. You do actually
need a scheduleuler. It doesn't matter
if it's cosign or linear, which is like
two very different things.
I'll take
it. I will take
it. And uh this is default batch size
and default BPD
horizon. So we can delete
these also default nums n workers all
this is default.
This is default. This is
default. Uh, so really the only things
we've changed, we've changed these two.
We probably should now go and fiddle
with these on other environments as
well. I'm just going to commit this
right, today has been a good day. Um,
for the folks watching, I'm getting
dinner. I might be back for a bit after
dinner. We're going to have to see how
I'm
feeling. This is a pretty solid result,
though. Let's just take a quick check at
this graph. This graph is also looking
fine. Cool. Um, if you're interested in
my work generally, tougher.ai, AI. You
want to help me out for free? Star the
GitHub. Really helps. If you want to get
involved in dev, join the Discord. It's
discord.gg/puffer. Our top contributors
actually mostly came in with zero RL
experience. So if you know how to
program, want to do some cool stuff, go
in and start writing some code with us.
Other than that, you can follow me on X
for